silver at hi guys its again and I'll
make with another part of the tutorial
or episode if you will I'll call it both
the part and an episode and my frame my
fps right now is not exactly the best
thing that has ever happened but I guess
I'll I'll manage this is a and this is a
problem with my crappy laptop and
perhaps being very heavy and it's early
in the morning so I'm being kind of
quiet so anyway like we've got this this
little wall on that cliff face over here
and I feel like it's it's not the
greatest thing so what I'm going to do
with this is something that I kind of
often do but then again I don't do it
very often but it's just a little trick
that you can do sometimes is I like this
I like to take station gyms fencing set
and take these wall columns to add some
detail to this this cliff face because
it's looking kind of boring and well
it's just one big cliff of rocks so I'm
just gonna add some details to this and
I'm gonna do that using this set just
gonna place a couple of these pillows to
make that look a bit less boring just
add some random detail to it that's not
a bad thing I would usually all also do
this corresponding to their fences on
top so for example if you use other
fences fences that do have to use these
wall columns then you can like make them
match up so I have a wall column on
their cliff face over here and then a
post in the fence
for example wooden fence over there so
that all matches up but in this case I
don't have that going on so this this
should do fine and this also can get you
rid of those weird transition pieces
except in this case I'm probably just
gonna do it like this that's probably
better than seeing that weird transition
piece because as you can see you can
kind of see that the little o and
elevation is always annoying you can
kind of see there little gaps where it
goes into a different wall piece okay
now this is a problem with with
terraforming ICT theory that you can't
really do anything about and the camera
position is based on how far from the
ground it's located and there's a little
cliff face over here and so yeah I can't
do anything about that and now for the
diagonal piece I am of course going to
do pick the diagonal columns but you've
got those as well in this set it's a
really great set I would really
recommend this for doing anything like
right now I'm using it for that for
those fences on top but you can also use
it for the stone things anyway I'm just
gonna continue along the wall here it's
a shame you can't
there aren't any pieces for these curved
pieces so you're just gonna have to let
that be like that so that's a bit
unfortunate but it's better than adding
random things that don't look good at
all now let's see I right now I'm using
a placement whereas every pillow is how
many 3/4 tiles away from a different
pillow but I would usually you can also
choose to use a system like this where
it's just two full tiles but right now I
just like using this and the fact that
this part is that there's a slightly
bigger distance over here doesn't really
matter that much you probably won't
notice that in pictures of anything
maybe if you have OCD but thankfully I
don't have that okay so I'm gonna need
that diagonal piece again for this place
and then if it all went well the wall
should look a bit more nice right now
yeah that's just slightly better it just
looks a bit cooler now what I see many
people always doing is they just leave
the sidewalk like this which is not
something that I would recommend so what
I would usually do is I take a set and
as of lately I am addicted to bright
inserts so I'll link that in the
description as well this is a great set
you can use that for the borders of the
sidewalks like I see many people not add
any borders to the site will turn looks
this but I think it looks it looks a lot
better when little borders like this
yeah you have to spend time on that so
that's a bit annoying but in the end I
think it looks a lot better so I'm just
gonna do that along the sidewalks oh
okay now that's just a bit of a boring
thing but like I said it's it's very
handy and in general it makes the
sidewalk look more site walky because in
real life you also have these like
little stone borders for the sidewalks
because their sidewalks should be kind
of more elevated and when you compare
them to the normal street but then again
you can't do that Andronicus taken three
so this is this is all you can do to
kind of create an illusion that the
sidewalk is slightly raised okay
now this has all the pieces in it that
shyguys sets have in it and as you can
see these are diagonal to straight
pieces but it even has the diagonals to
straight pieces and curves that shyguy
uses and called shine in this case so
this is a really great set it works with
any fence set sir it works with any path
set so I would really recommend this set
plus the textures are pretty good in it
as well it's not the best excuse ever
but it's it's it's good enough and I
like some textures like this but what's
actually I really like and now there are
also plugs for like these very small
gaps as you can see but I don't think
that's too much of a problem you usually
don't really see that but if you really
feel like filling that up because you
have OCD or something I don't even know
then you can take these plugs I think
it's just plug one yeah and kind of do
it like that but I feel like I don't
want to see that circle on it either so
this is probably better for fences for
example anyway that's that's that then
I'm gonna have to do that over here as
well but I think I'm going to do that
fencing first and now comes the hard
part of doing a transition of having a
sidewalk - not having a sidewalk so I'm
going to take Costa Jose path away
extensions again
and just quickly finish that up I kind
of want to have the sight walk going in
right the roller-coaster so you can have
a nice little view of it so I'm just
gonna continue this along the way I
think until you have that ramp point
because frankly I won't be able to add
sight walks on terraform parts like this
you can of course because there are some
sets that have conforming path pieces
but then again it's it's kind of
annoying to work with and it's not the
greatest thing and I see some people
like the mistake that I've made many
times at site walks everywhere but if
you go to a real theme park they don't
add sidewalks everywhere like sidewalks
in most of the major places especially
main streets main streets really need
those things I've been heavily themed
areas usually I have them and coaster
panoramas like these of course do you
have sidewalks but not everything has
sidewalks so it would probably be a good
idea to leave them out at some places
okay then now I feel like actually no
the sidewalk should kind of disappear
like this in a way let's see that the
real path is going to go over there and
no no no that's weird you either have to
include the sidewalk in there and how
white the path is or not so example you
could say that this is the path over
here and then the sidewalk should just
stop over here and also make the path a
bit more narrow but you can also say
that the sidewalk should stop into that
direction and just make the middle path
wider but that just depends on whatever
the situation is I'm still kind of
debating what I should do over here I
think I'm gonna end it like this even
though I usually don't really like this
as much it's probably my best bet in
this case because this leads up to the
rocks that I have over there so that
makes more sense in general also that
means I can have some straight fences on
the kind of the slope apart
and that's something you want to have
because conforming fences that have
curves in them that have all the curves
in them that this son has for example
you don't that doesn't really exist and
if it would exist it would be very
annoying so I'm just gonna leave that
out and over here I don't have any of
those any of those rocks to deal with
and it doesn't have to make a turn
slightly slightly too into this
direction anyway so I'm just gonna add
the sight walk in that direction right
now that should work I already did that
over here so this should be fine though
I did add a slightly weird transition
over here I probably shouldn't do that I
should probably do it like like this
yeah I should let's see mm-hmm though to
be fair that path does go all the way
over there so you know I'm just gonna
try it like this
yeah and then before I forget it that'll
be the last thing I do in this episode I
can kind of turn this into a small path
stuff tips episode and borders episode
I'm gonna add the same borders then I
add it on the cliff side Brian's borders
just gonna take those back rock ones
they're probably my favorite texture
from this set but it also has other
textures like recolor ball textures a
recolor of all version of this one and
many great things like wood and concrete
it's a great set
okay now the terraforming is kind of
annoying so I'm just gonna hold ctrl to
keep it the same elevation okay so I
need some of these normal diagonal to
straights because this is not a shot
guy's path set wait he doesn't wait he
yeah he does have paths okay I'm just
gonna finish this over here and another
small diagonal over there the rest
shouldn't be too annoying with that
terraforming so I probably shouldn't
have to you
is controlled at the control at this
point
okay now this looked like that oh it's a
it's a four curve
okay now this displacement is a bit
annoying but it's good enough okay and
then I'm almost done with this
let's see some diagonal to straights I
think this looks like an A yeah and then
I'm gonna do that straight things first
just because there's more of that okay
this all works and then last but not
least one day no parts the diagonal
double is a full title so that's what
I'd recommend using okay so that's nice
so we've got a nice little we've kind of
made there cliff side a bit nicer and
we've added some nice little sidewalk
borders so that's pretty cool and I
think in the next episode I'm just gonna
finish the path with more offenses stuff
like that so see you then